I have a hot constitution.
The East for me was a constant hell realm.
The only thing that helped was a fan.
l'unica cosa che era di un po' di aiuto era un ventilatore che avevo proprio lì davanti a me infortunatamente, penso che avrei potuto dire questo, infortunatamente suonava come un aeroplano che in momenti di maledizione pensavo fosse andando a migliorare i plani di esistenza
E nei momenti di follia avevo l'impressione che mi portasse a dei livelli più alti di esistenza.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Samma Sambuddhassa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasam Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasam Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
Ommaggio al Buddha, al Beato, al Nobile e al pienamente Illuminato.
Quindi stasera pensavo di nuovo di ripassare per alcuni di voi che già riconoscono i concetti del karma.
E ovviamente per uno o due di voi sarà un nuovo insegnamento.
e per uno o due di voi sarà un nuovo insegnamento quindi il punto di partenza da cui mi piace iniziare è dal modo in cui effettivamente il Buddha ha visto funzionare come funzionava l'universo in Pali si chiama Iddha Pachayatah
Il condizionamento di questo e quello.
Inizialmente sembra straordinariamente semplice.
Ma explica perché le cose succedono nell'universo.
ma questo spiega perché le cose accadono nell'universo o meglio come le cose accadono nell'universo ricordate che la domanda del Buddha era come piuttosto che un perché più filosofico o metafisico non è preoccupato con la domanda delle origini dell'universo
I think as far as he was concerned the origin is right here and now.
Because he says somewhere that he does not see a beginning to karma.
It's impossible to rationally think that there was a beginning or an end to the constant flow of cause and effect.
E' impossibile pensare che ci fosse un inizio o una fine al costante flusso degli eventi.
Come sapete nella cosmologia buddista i sistemi dei vari mondi sorgono e svaniscono.
come enormi ispirazioni e ispirazioni cosmiche quindi questa iddha pacchiatà questa condizione la prima clausola è perché questo è successo questo succede ora
Quindi in questo idpacietà, il condizionamento di questo e quello, allora il primo sintaco, il primo presupposto è che poiché è successo questo, quello accadrà.
Quindi questo è come capire il causo e l'effetto.
Quindi questo è come noi normalmente capiamo la legge di causa-effetto.
Quindi, poiché non avete pagato le bollette, finirete per essere sbattuto fuori dalla vostra casa.
È molto semplice.
Quindi uno riesce a vedere una sorta di linea storica riguardo a cosa succede.
E quindi vale anche l'opposto cioè se non fai questo quello non accadrà.
Se non vi comprate un biglietto della lotteria non vincerete mai alla lotteria.
Sto suggerendo di comprare un biglietto della lotteria.
Queste sono cose innocenti sono solo degli esempi.
E quindi la seconda proposizione è poiché questo accade ora, questo succede.
E quindi poiché questo non succede, quest'altro non succede.
Quindi per esempio, poiché tutti siete arrivati qui ora, questo sta creando un momento speciale.
Quindi in altre parole, poiché siete tutti venuti qui adesso, questo sta creando un momento speciale.
Se voi non foste venuti non ci sarebbe un discorso.
E io sarei libero di far prendermi una tazza di tè.
Quindi, se prendiamo questa prima proposizione, cioè come normalmente la gente pensa la legge di causa-effetto, cioè poiché quello è successo nel passato, questo sta succedendo adesso, allora si avvicina a quello che il Buddha penserebbe di essere un errore.
allora cadresti in quello che il Buddha giudicherebbe un errore.
E quindi è la teoria del fatalismo.
Le cose capitano, non abbiamo nessuna scelta perché sono già state programmate nel passato.
C'era un insegnante ai tempi del Buddha che pensava esattamente così.
Lui diceva che se voi andavate giù lungo una riva del film Ganji facendo solo azioni benevole, facendo il bene e poste tornate dall'altra riva del Ganji facendo solo azioni malvagie questo non avrebbe fatto nessuna differenza.
Quindi c'era questa idea del fatalismo anche nei tempi del Buddha.
questo capita anche nel cristianesimo con il calvinismo e quindi Calvino diceva se Dio sa tutto quindi lui sa se tu finirai all'inferno oppure no quindi non c'è nulla che tu puoi fare c'è tutto scritto nella mente di Dio e finalmente non c'è nulla che tu puoi fare
E quindi alla fine non importava se tu facessi del bene o del male, perché eri già predestinato.
È proprio chiamata la dottrina della predestinazione.
E poiché gli esseri umani non possono assumere questo tipo di fatalismo,
Quindi è venuta la cosiddetta etica protestante.
E quindi questo significava che se voi vi fosse comportati bene in questa vita, questo sicuramente avrebbe comportato l'ingresso nel paradiso.
Quindi il capitalismo.
questa è la fine del capitalismo one cause it causes capitalism one of the reasons è una delle motivi che ha causato il capitalismo if you only take the first proposition
Quindi se si prende solo questo assunto, insomma, di un punto di vista storico, che è quello che è successo in passato, poi si ripercuota sul presente, allora finirete con l'idea di un universo che semplicemente si ripete.
Che nulla cambia.
Now, if you take the other proposition, that things happen now because things happen now, in other words, contingency, so, for instance, we all came from very different places and we all came because of our own decision making, but we all ended up in this place to create this course.
Quindi in altre parole noi tutti siamo venuti da posti diversi con delle nostre personali intenzioni e ci siamo ritrovati tutti insieme a creare questo momento in questo luogo.
Quindi il trovarci tutti qui in questo momento crea quella causa.
Quindi se non c'è nessun collegamento tra il presente e il passato uno può supporre che allora l'universo sarebbe caotico.
Siamo i due estremi da un lato che tutto è predestinato e dall'altro che tutto è caotico.
E a volte può sembrare caotico quando ci sono gli tsunami per esempio o i terremoti
E sembra che non ce ne sia una ragione.
Quindi quando metti questi due concetti insieme, che è difficile, quando metti questi due concetti insieme, allora hai un'idea dal punto di vista del Buddha di come il mondo rimane in un stato di ordine e non è creato.
quindi se si riesce a mettere insieme questi due concetti allora si capisce dal punto di vista buddista di come l'universo è allo stesso tempo ordinato ma creativo quindi per noi come meditatori questo è importante perché vedete tornando alla nostra pratica di notare l'intenzione
Perché adesso tornando alla nostra pratica del notare l'intenzione.
Se la consapevolezza non c'è, allora è come se tutta la nostra vita corresse a seconda della prima proposizione che abbiamo fatto.
Quindi noi stiamo vivendo, stiamo andando avanti come un automa, secondo i vecchi condizionamenti.
Quando portiamo la consapevolezza in una situazione improvvisamente sorgono altre possibilità.
E quindi abbiamo una scelta.
Devo fare così o devo fare così.
E quindi abbiamo quell'impressione di essere più in controllo della nostra vita e più creativi.
E quindi
Quando il sé, a quel punto in cui il sé completamente sparisce, anche nelle piccole azioni della nostra vita, questo significa che il vecchio condizionamento non sta avendo un effetto diretto sul presente e uno ha l'impressione di spontaneità.
Per esempio uno pratica la generosità, ma c'è sempre qualche pensiero riguardo.
Ma perché noi praticiamo in modo giusto, subito esce un'occasione per la generosità e lo facciamo senza pensare.
Poi noi pratichiamo bene e sorge l'occasione per praticare la generosità e noi la facciamo senza pensare, spontaneamente.
Ed è buono e saggio.
Sì.
Quindi queste due cose, cioè questo senso di spontaneità e di avere un maggior controllo sulla nostra vita, sono cose che crescono con noi man mano che...
sorry I was thinking ahead then so I lost you I was wondering what I was going to say next so keeping that fundamental law you can call that your basic fundamental law of cause and effect
Quindi possiamo chiamarla la nostra legge fondamentale di causa-effetto.
La seconda cosa che possiamo dire è che il Buddha non ha detto che le cose capitano a seconda del nostro karma personale.
Lui ha parlato di cinque cause per le quali le cose capitano.
Queste non verranno come una sorpresa.
Il primo è Uttuniyama.
E' la legge del calore.
Ed è come gli antichi pensavano al mondo fisico.
So everything began with heat and everything else appears out of heat.
Quindi tutto è cominciato dal calore e tutto viene fuori, nasce dal calore.
E quindi questo corrisponderebbe alla nostra fisica.
Quindi se per caso vi capite di camminare in giro per Monte Santo e viene un terremoto che vi inghiotte nella terra,
Non è perché nella vostra vita passata avete calpestato centomila formiche.
È perché era il momento che la montagna creasse questo terremoto.
era solo questa creatività dell'universo che infortunatamente è stata lì allo stesso momento.
Il nostro calma attuale, e tornerò a questo, in questa situazione, non è l'errore, ma come reagiamo a questo.
Quindi il nostro vero karma, ci tornerà più tardi, in quella situazione non è il terremoto, ma come noi reagiamo a quel terremoto.
La seconda legge, Niyama, è Bija Niyama.
Bija significa seme.
E qui il seme si riferisce a quello che noi chiameremo la genetica.
Qui abbiamo il caso, per esempio, di qualcuno che nasce con una malattia genetica.
E sarebbe molto sbagliato pensare che quella persona merita quella malattia perché nella vita passata ha agito in modo tale da causare quella malattia.
Perché come sappiamo, solo dalla nostra stessa scienza, la nostra malattia genetica è un composto di centinaia di morti e morti che non hanno nulla a che fare con noi.
Sì, abbiamo finito con questo corpo.
E ancora una volta, è la nostra relazione con il corpo che è il nostro carma vero.
e di nuovo è la nostra relazione col corpo che è il nostro vero karma quando stavo al monastero di Ambaravati in Inghilterra c'era un uomo che venne a fare un ritiro e aveva una malattia genetica in cui il suo corpo stava diventando stifato e rilassato
Aveva una malattia genetica in base alla quale il suo corpo si stava ripiegando su se stesso, stava diventando rigido.
Sembrava che lui fosse a suo agio con la sua situazione.
L'ha accettato, ha lavorato con lui e viveva una vita spirituale molto bella.
Quindi lui è arrivato ad accettarlo, conviveva e stava conducendo una buona vita spirituale.
Quindi quando questo gli è successo da ragazzo i suoi genitori hanno chiesto ai medici se poteva ripetersi perché loro volevano avere un altro figlio.
Quindi sarebbe stato un caso rarissimo, uno su un milione.
E quindi ebbero un'altra bambina.
Ma sfortunatamente anche lei ha sviluppato questa malattia genetica.
Ma la sua relazione con il corpo in cui era molto diversa.
Ma la sua relazione con il corpo nel quale si trovava era molto diversa.
Dicono, lui non l'ha mai conosciuto, che era molto amareggiato.
Quindi di nuovo non dobbiamo confondere la nostra costituzione genetica con il nostro karma.
Il terzo niyama è citta e quella è la mente.
E la mente qui è la nostra psicologia.
Quindi abbiamo detto ieri che la prima parte della ruota dell'originazione dipendente, cioè i sei sensi, il contatto e le sensazioni che esolgono, sono solo naturali nella nostra psicologia.
Sono naturali nella nostra psicologia.
E tutti gli esseri sensienti devono avere quell'abilità di contattare il mondo e avere quelle sensazioni.
Poi c'è tutta la psicologia intorno alla nostra non comprensione, all'attaccamento, eccetera.
Ma in questo termine citta possiamo includere tutto ciò che noi comprendiamo con il termine psicologia, con quello che noi intendiamo come psicologia.
E alcuni scrittori, in particolare si riferisce a uno scrittore thailandese che scrive dei libri molto buoni.
Paiuto è il suo nome.
P-A-Y-T-O P-A P-A-Y-T-O
se andate nel motore di ricerca a Google e mettete Paiuto viene fuori il suo sito lui collega questo citta con la società quindi la società in cui viviamo è davvero un'estensione delle menti umane
Quindi la società in cui viviamo è un'estensione delle menti umane.
Ricordate che il primo verso del Dhammapada inizia che tutto inizia con la mente e tutto è fatto dalla mente.
Per esempio, bisogna un essere umano pensare a una strada prima di poterla costruire.
Quindi ci va un essere umano che pensi ad una strada prima di effettivamente costruirla.
In altre parole noi stiamo costantemente proiettando i nostri pensieri sul mondo.
Le nostre immagini, i nostri progetti.
Anche quando parliamo di una foresta naturale, è molto raro di trovare una che non sia stata medaldata da umani.
Quindi c'è una connessione tra tutta la psicologia che il Buddha sta insegnando e la società in cui viviamo.
Quindi c'è un collegamento tra tutta la psicologia, così come insegna il Buddha, e la società nella quale viviamo.
C'è una parte del nostro
Quindi c'è una parte del nostro modo di pensare, della nostra mente, che è condizionata dalla società in cui viviamo.
Quindi quando si parla delle leggi fisiche e delle leggi delle genetiche e del nostro mente, per la maggior parte, tutte queste sono date.
Per quanto riguarda le leggi fisiche, quelle della genetica e la nostra mente, queste sono cose che ci vengono date.
Quindi anche a un livello molto basi là è come la vista.
se una persona non vede i colori vede il mondo in un modo diverso è una cosa che gli è stata data così è una cosa che ha ricevuto non ha nessuna scelta ma questo non ha nulla a che vedere con il processo della liberazione o almeno non direttamente
non direttamente sarebbe bello crescere in una società che fosse più spirituale della nostra allora si avrebbe quel sostegno sociale per l'addestramento spirituale il quarto è il karma
e qui torniamo davanti alla ruota dell'originazione dipendente quindi qui torniamo davanti a questa idea di importanza delle intenzioni
quindi torniamo a questa idea dell'importanza delle intenzioni e quindi che noi stiamo costantemente costruendo una relazione con il mondo che noi percepiamo e che per la maggior parte del tempo noi agiamo in un modo non consapevole
almeno come meditatori stiamo diventando un pochino più consapevoli del nostro condizionamento ma basta entrare in un supermercato e osservare la gente e vedrete che sono in un mondo di sogno e non questionano nulla è quello che è la loro vita
E non mettono nulla in discussione, quella è la loro vita.
Non so se avete visto il film Matrix.
E' una bella metafora per il modo in cui siamo, come siamo fatti.
Quando creiamo queste intenzioni, ricordate, produciamo un'azione.
Quindi quando creiamo queste intenzioni noi produciamo un'azione.
E queste azioni producono abitudini che producono la nostra personalità.
Ed è questa personalità che ci guida al nostro destino.
Quindi se diventiamo consapevoli di questi condizionamenti noi possiamo spostare un pochino spostare le condizioni diciamo in modo da cambiare anche il nostro destino.
Sfortunatamente gli esseri umani hanno bisogno di sbattere il naso fortemente prima di farlo.
Devi avere un infarto o un ictus e poi pensi oh, qualcosa è sbagliato forse.
ma forse c'è qualcosa che non va ma fortunatamente noi non dovremmo aspettare che capiti qualcosa di questo genere perché forse noi ci siamo un po' risvegliati rispetto a come stiamo creando sofferenza a noi stessi
E questo può significare che noi cambiamo le nostre vite, cambiamo i nostri atteggiamenti.
Quindi solo perché facciamo qualcosa di buono nel mondo non significa che qualcosa di buono tornerà a noi.
Lì fuori non esiste una giustizia umana.
Perché quando voi buttate qualcosa nel mondo non sapete quale condizioni potrà creare.
Quindi ricordate che il mondo nasce da diverse condizioni che si incontrano in un dato momento.
Allora per esempio c'era un'organizzazione benefica in un piccolo paese nel sud dell'Inghilterra e hanno pensato di mandare vestiti in Africa.
Quindi hanno mandato molti e molti vestiti in questo particolare paese.
Quindi hanno mandato un sacco di vestiti in questo posto particolare.
Sfortunatamente questo ha rovinato il commercio degli abiti in quel posto.
e quindi tutta l'economia è cominciata a entrare in crisi quindi sebbene il pensiero fosse molto compassionevole
Non conoscendo le condizioni di quel paese, questa scelta non è stata molto saggia.
Quindi si potrebbe dire che uno non è mai abbastanza saggio, perché non conosce mai le condizioni di quella particolare situazione.
Anche il Buddha, quando ha fatto le regole, non sapeva le conseguenze delle sue regole, e poi ha dovuto mettere piccole clausole per correggersi.
Anche il Buddha stesso quando ha dettato delle regole non sapeva quali fossero le condizioni in cui andavano ad agire quelle regole.
Ha dovuto mettere delle note per correggere quelle regole.
Per esempio ha messo questa regola per via del fatto che c'erano alcuni monaci che sostenevano di avere degli insight spirituali mentre invece non ne avevano.
Allora ha messo questa regola che nessuno ne poteva parlare.
Allora poi i monaci si sono lamentati e hanno detto ma come facciamo a sapere se qualcuno ha avuto qualche insight spirituale?
allora ho dovuto aggiungere a meno che non fossero veri in tante parole
questa regola è una delle nostre regole principali e se non si segue questa regola non si è più monaco o monaca è chiamata una sconfitta sconfitta
Quindi anche se non lasciano l'abito però dentro di sé loro sanno di avere infranto questa regola e quindi non si considerano più monaci, monaco o monaca.
In realtà non c'è nessun modo nell'ordine buddista, diciamo, di fare gli ordini buddisti, in cui si può fare...
in cui si possa togliere l'abito non si può essere scomunicati come togliere l'abito ma si può essere smonacati come negli ordini cattolici
quello che succede è che se gli altri monaci insieme anche ai laici credono che un monaco abbia non rispettato questa regola gli chiedono di lasciare il monastero e poi smettono di dargli da mangiare e quindi devi togliere l'arbitro per avere del cibo
ma di solito se un monaco infrange questa legge questa regola lascia spontaneamente ma di solito non dicono che per questa ragione danno qualche altra motivazione per esempio sentono troppo la mancanza del pasto serale
ma c'erano anche delle regole minori dove il Buddha ha dovuto cambiare idea una volta ha starnutito e tutti i monaci e i monaci intorno a lui hanno detto qualcosa che era equivalente a salute il Dio serio?
in inglese si dice che Dio ti benedica che Dio ti benedica in inglese si dice così e lui gli ha chiesto ma questo mi aiuta e loro hanno detto no e lui ha detto allora non lo dite
I monaci poi sono andati in giro e quando i laici stannuttivano loro non dicevano più niente.
I laici sono andati in giro e gli sono lamentati e hanno detto ma perché i monaci non ci benedicano quando abbiamo la perdona?
E allora sono andato dal Buddha e gli ho detto, ma tutti i laici si stanno lamentando.
E allora lui mi ha detto, va bene, benediceteli.
Non fa del bene, ma non fa neanche del male.
Quindi abbiamo molti esempi nella storia in cui le persone migliori poi finiscono nei modi più tragici.
non solo Gesù Cristo ma Gandhi Martin Luther King quindi vedete solo perché fate del bene il bene ti arriverà ma all'interno di voi stessi prendete i benefici del fare bene questo è il grande cuore il grande cuore
Questo è il grande cuore, la grande anima.
E questo è il vostro karma.
Sì.
E quindi, come ultimo, c'è il Dhamma.
Quindi questi sono tutti gli insegnamenti del Buddha che hanno a che vedere con la liberazione.
Quindi qui avete le cinque leggi e vedete bene dove si inserisce il karma.
Anche se io ho voluto sottolineare il fatto che pur facendo del bene non necessariamente questo vi ritorna
comunque qualche volta si e lo stesso quando fate male spesso vi ritorna il male quindi ora ovviamente avendo discutito questo siamo arrivati al problema se tutto questo succede solo in una vita e non raggiungi la liberazione che pittura
che se tutto questo capita in una vita e se tu non raggiungi la liberazione è un vero peccato e quindi occorre conoscere questa legge della rinascita e anche se può essere difficile per alcune persone ad accettare sento sempre che ci sono alcune cose che possiamo mantenere come se fossero sul rinascita
anche se questa è una teoria difficile da accettare per alcune persone però la possiamo sempre tenere come una cosa di scorta insomma nello sfondo come avete presente le vecchie stufe che si mette qualcosa nella una scaldavivanda una cosa di scorta diciamo da tenere lì in caso di necessità non fate una decisione
Quindi non prendete una decisione.
Quindi tenete la mente aperta a quella possibilità.
Perché se credete nell'annichilamento alla morte potreste essere sorpresi.
Sì, in maniera sfortunata.
Spiacevolmente sorpresi.
C'è stata una vignetta quando è morto il Papa.
man mano che saliva nelle nuvole del cielo si è trovato la presenza di un enorme stato del Buddha allora ha detto oh, all'inferno all'inferno in inglese è un'espressione accidente quindi non si sa mai ma
Come sapete l'ultimo Papa non aveva dei buoni sentimenti nei confronti del buddista.
Infatti lui aveva creato fatto arrabbiare
Il sangue dello Sri Lanka, così tanto che loro si sono rifiutati di riceverlo quando è andato in visita.
Quindi, anche se non vogliamo accettare la qualità del rinascimento dopo la morte, dobbiamo iniziare a capire che in realtà è quello che sta succedendo qui e ora.
Quindi anche se non vogliamo accettare questa qualità della rinascita nelle vite successive dobbiamo però riconoscere quello che sta succedendo qui e ora.
Prendete il corpo per esempio.
Il corpo con cui siamo nati non è lo stesso nel quale ci troviamo adesso.
Ci dicono che ogni sette anni ogni atomo del nostro corpo è diverso, cambia.
Quindi ogni volta che vi guardate nello specchio dite al vostro viso sette anni fa non c'eri.
C'è questa continua rinascita all'interno del corpo, cellule che muoiono, cellule che nascono, un cambiamento continuo.
Continua ad essere rinato.
E lo stesso vale per la mente.
La mente che avete adesso non è la stessa con la quale siete nati.
Ogni volta che entra un pezzo nuovo di informazione, la mente si rinodella, viene cambiata.
Quindi è capito, nella lezione del Buddha, che quando il corpo si toglie, il corpo sottile si esce da lui.
Quindi si capisce dagli insegnamenti buddhisti che quando il corpo fisico decade, quello spirituale sorge da esso.
Ed è conosciuto come il corpo di citta, quello mentale.
E questo cerca la rinascita da qualche altra parte, o come essere umano o in un altro regno.
Come sapete ci sono delle persone che vivono determinate esperienze quando sono sottoposte ad un intervento chirurgico.
E ci sono due esperienze fuori dal corpo.
Quello in cui la persona lasciava il corpo
Allora uno è quello quando uno lascia il corpo e vede il corpo mentale separato dal corpo fisico.
Questo fa ancora parte del mondo fenomenico.
Io ero in un ritrito una volta in cui una donna diceva che stava seduta lì e si è uscita da un corpo e ha camminato tutto il percorso del giardino e è tornata.
ho conosciuto una donna in un ritiro che diceva che lei è uscita completamente dal corpo è andata giù per il giardino poi è ritornata e avevo un meditatore che lavorava con me che diceva che aveva questo corpo che continuamente usciva dal corpo fisico quindi questo è il primo tipo di esperienza fuori dal corpo
La seconda esperienza di cui potreste aver sentito parlare è per usare una parola...
Per quanto riguarda una parola migliore.
E quando la coscienza esce dal corpo.
Questa sentite la maggior parte come esperienze vicine alla morte.
E questo a volte lo sentite parlare come esperienze vicino alla morte.
Ci sono anche dei libri su questo, non so in italiano, Near Death Experiences.
c'è stato un programma molto buono sulla BBC che, attraverso la tecnologia moderna, era in grado di darvi una rappresentazione visiva di ciò che queste persone avevano esperienza.
In una delle interviste con uno psicologo, hanno spiegato che quando questa persona è uscita dal corpo durante un'operazione, hanno descritto cose che non avrebbero potuto vedere con gli occhi della persona.
quindi hanno dimostrato che questa persona che per esempio è uscita dal corpo durante un intervento chirurgico ha poi descritto delle cose lungo il corridoio per esempio fuori dalla sala operatoria che non poteva aver visto con i suoi occhi da quella posizione e quando hanno chiesto a questo psichiatra qual era la sua opinione lui gli disse noi dovremmo ridefinire la coscienza
quindi quando questa consapevolezza esce ed è separata dal corpo fisico e mentale questa è un'esperienza spirituale e capita alle persone anche durante la meditazione
Quindi, tutto ciò che succede, nulla succede a morte, a meno che il corpo, il corpo fisico, falla fuori.
Quindi nulla capita alla morte, al momento della morte, tranne che il corpo fisico termina, finisce.
Tutto il condizionamento continua ad andare avanti.
E ovviamente, quando siamo finalmente liberati,
ma quando siamo finalmente liberati allora si arriva a un punto che va oltre la descrizione ma di nuovo non dobbiamo confonderlo con una forma di annichilimento quindi spesso al Buddha venivano fatte queste quattro domande
era conosciuto come il quadrilemma il dilemma sono due domande il quadrilemma sono quattro quindi alla morte il Tathagata esiste o non esiste esiste e non esiste allo stesso tempo
Oppure né esiste né non esiste.
Silenzioso, zitto.
Quindi queste cose dobbiamo scoprirle noi stessi con il tempo.
Quindi, per noi, come meditatori cercando la liberazione, è chiaro che il processo è contenuto nelle sue parole molto semplici.
Quindi per noi che cerchiamo la liberazione dobbiamo capire che è tutto contenuto nelle parole del Buddha.
Molto semplice.
Molto semplicemente contenuto nelle parole del Buddha.
Che insegna solo tre parole, no?
lui insegna solo tre parole le leggi della relatività sono cinque parole ma gli insegnamenti del Buddha sono chiusi in tre parole in Pali io insegno solo Dukkha Dukkha Nirodha
quindi la insoddisfazione è la fine della insoddisfazione quindi se la nostra ricerca nei insegnamenti del Buddha va in questa direzione allora ci porterà ad una risposta
Se ci sediamo in silenzio per qualche minuto e lasciamo che i pensieri sorgono o passino.
quindi il sentiero per la liberazione è ben delineato quindi si dice che noi abbiamo una scelta tra fare delle cose abili e non abili ma più facciamo delle cose non abili e non salutari più soffriamo
Quindi in un certo senso non abbiamo scelta.
Quando vediamo il sentiero dobbiamo semplicemente seguirlo.
Spero che le mie parole siano state di una certa utilità per voi.
Mi auguro che voi siate liberati prima piuttosto che poi.
Grazie.